like a great example being Dead Poet
Society okay Ben and I got close on that
right we both auditioned we both got
called back and I was like this is a
amazing movie and I was probably
17 or 18. we didn't get it when it came
out Ben and I worked at a movie theater
in Cambridge Massachusetts and the one
movie they played all summer was dead
so you go from the possibility of being
in the movie
to the guy tearing the ticket and
watching people come out crying because
they're so moved and it's like wow like
that's the range of possibility for you
if you go into that business and we were
like that could have been us and I think
those are the experiences that they
either Crush you or they they endure you
to the realities of this business but
having said that we did get called back
so the business was telling us it didn't
work out this time
but
you're doing some some things right you
know and then you need to get
extraordinarily lucky for us they just
it made us more determined I think